[موسيقى]
نحن هنا على الحدود غروف في
خليج ماندالاي في لاس فيجاس ، وقد طهيت الشيف ماري
سو ميليكين مع بعض
البرغر اللذيذ لنا اليوم بما في ذلك
هذه المنزلقات الصغيرة الصغيرة وهناك
شيء مختلف قليلاً عنها
فهي الوصفة الجديدة  من
البرجر المستحيل الذي يعد بديلاً نباتيًا
تمامًا للهامبرغر ، حسنًا ،
دعنا نتذوق قليلاً
إنه برجر صغير جيد حقًا مرحباً ماري
سو كنت أتساءل عما إذا كان بإمكانك قطع
البرجر ، توضح لنا كاثي ما هو
اللحم المزيف حقًا.
مثل ذلك جيدًا تمامًا ، فهذه واحدة من
الأشياء الرائعة في هذه البرغر هي
أنك تعلم أنها مصنوعة حقًا لمحبي اللحوم
ليس كثيرًا للنباتيين ،
أعني بالنظر إلى اللون هناك ، لا يزال
هناك القليل من اللون الوردي والعصير وهو
يلبي حقًا تحولنا من  من القمح إلى
الصويا كان يعتمد حقًا على
أمرين تمكنا من الحصول على مضغ أفضل بكثير
مع فول الصويا ، جودة البروتين
أفضل ووجدنا أنه مع
مزيج من المكونات  يمكن في
الواقع الحصول على طعم أفضل بهذه الطريقة
أيضًا ، فهو مشابه بشكل ملحوظ
للحم البقري المفروم الحقيقي وهذا نوع
مذهل وسأكون متحمسًا لأنه يحتوي على نسبة
أقل من الصوديوم وكوليسترول
أقل ودهون أقل ، لذلك سأختاره على اللحم البقري
لنفسي وأنا آكل لحوم كبيرة